hello and welcome to the shaky sideshow
in today's video we're going to look at
prime editing implants so u prime
editing is the form of genome editing
that I spoke about in a previous video
about the technique and how it works but
in this video we'll look at how prime
editing can now be applied to plants as
reported in this recent Nature
Biotechnology paper so whilst I do have
quite an elaborate and entertaining
video about prime editing I will just
reintroduce the concept behind prime
editing here so prime editors are crisp
Lacasse tiny cases that are fused to
reverse transcriptase so kustanai
normally cuts both strands of DNA whilst
the catheline decays would only cut one
strand and say this is the protein part
and it's programmed with prime editing
go donees of always known as peg rnase
and these recruits the cut my protein
into the target sites that you want to
have the genome edits so I will go into
the technology and a little bit more
detail here but I would advise you to
watch the previous video where I go into
a lot more detail if you don't really
understand the concepts yet so the
overview of this video will be to
explain a little bit more about the
concept behind prime editing just to
give you the key take-home messages
about how it works
I bet how they can apply this technology
to plants and why they'd want to do it
and then I got some funky sub headings
that son of a fig at moments that's will
make complete sense when we get to it so
let's start with further explaining the
concepts behind prime editing so
currently you're looking at the cast 9
decays and this is the H 80 40 a class 9
and so this cuts a single strand which
is the non-target strand to what the
guide RNA recognizes and you can see
that cut line is fused to this reverse
transcriptase and you can see that in
prime editing the guide RNA is actually
extended
such that it can bind further down the
target site and contain the targeted
genome edits in the sequence such that
the reverse transcriptase can then copy
those edits into the DNA sequence so in
other words the guide RNA is technically
the primer for the referral
scrapp days that will then transcribe
the design edits
and that will then get incorporated into
the genome which is I think what the
name prime medicine comes from don't
know ways to think pretty sure that's
the reason why it's called prime editing
but anyway I've redrawn this out now
without the cast line so you can just
see the prime edited guide RNA sequence
and so you can see it's got the guide
part at the five prime end which is
going to bind to the targeted gene name
sites and then at the three prime end
you see the prime the primer sites that
recognizes the similar site which is
downstream and contains the decides
genome edits that I wanted to be
incorporated into the DNA sequence and
so that's the reverse transcriptase
templates that will include in the edits
and so in the first paper where they
describe the technology a primary thing
they tried different versions of this
prime editing technology to see what was
best and say PvE
is now standing for plants prime editing
because this has come from the most
recent publication and you can see
there's two three and three B and these
are just slight variations of the same
technique but just modified in a
slightly different ways the key
difference is that in three and three B
there is an additional guide RNA that
binds the sites just a little bit
downstream of the target sites whereas
in Jason cynic and the non edited strand
to promote the incorporation of the
edited change as opposed to the non
edited change if that makes sense so the
development of this technology was done
in mammalian cells so the question
behind this paper was could it be
applied to you plants and say well why
would you want to do this well one
reason is to accelerates crop
improvement and breeding which is to try
and you know resolve this food crisis
that's you know that's will be nine
point six billion the population by 2050
and there isn't enough crops to go about
and so you can use genome editing
techniques to modify the traits such as
improving resistance to pathogens and
improving their crop growth rates as I
elaborate a little bit more in this
video about super foods
and secondly the current techniques we
have to edit its plants is quite
challenging so when using the canonical
cast nine genome editing system you
induce a double strand break in the
targeted sites and seven cells there are
two main mechanisms for repairing double
strand breaks non-homologous end joining
which is a error-prone methods or a more
precise method which is homology
directed repair which depends upon a
donor template that contains the desired
change so implants there is a two-fold
problem one being that homology directed
repair has a lower efficiency than seen
in mammalian cells and secondly those
difficulty with delivering the DNA
templates containing the desired edits
so this was the motivation behind
primary theme but you don't have any
double strand breaks and you don't need
the donor DNA templates so that is all
good and well but how do you actually
modify prime editing to be able to use
it implants so that was the aim of the
paper and so they effectively optimized
prime emiting for a variety of changes
in the code on the promoter and also in
editing conditions which will come back
to a little bit later and they try all
these different conditions do you see
where everything was best
so that's including most efficient and
with the lowest amount of undersides
changes and so initially they used a
reporter system to be able to see where
editing is occurring effectively and
this reporter system is a fluorescent
space system whereby you want to edit a
blue fluorescent protein into a green
fluorescent protein and then you can
detect the fluorescence color not I mean
I split color but you know what I mean
and so if editing is successful you by
changing just one codon from C AC to TAC
you turn this blue protein into a green
protein and so the number of cells that
are green gives you a readout on the
editing efficiency so I've taken this
figure from the paper and so you can see
that they have an extra control and a
positive control where they've just got
cells that or always Express a green
fluorescent protein and then if you look
at some of the other conditions so the
first one is actually a plant-based
editor
I'll explain bass editing a little bit
it's just another alternative editing
system and then the PPE 3b is the prime
editing system that they're trying to
modify and you can see that 4.4 percent
roughly half of the cells are green so
that gives you a readout of the ansan
efficiency so to go from a blue throw
some pretty into a green one that
requires a substitution in the
nucleotide sequence but what about
editing and including other genetic
modifications so to summon this in
primary cilium plants they moved to
endogenous genes and rice and weeds and
they tested to see if they could include
six base pay deletions three based
parent sessions and single nucleotide
modifications for example going from as
had seen to time in so just to mention
some of the editing efficiencies they
achieved with these modifications they
got around a twenty percent success rate
with the deletions around two percent
with the insertions and they also did
see some success with the single
nucleotide changes and so this last one
is very similar to what can currently be
achieved with base editing techniques
which as I mentioned is an alternative
genome editing technique that doesn't
include any breaks in the genome and it
can currently do you tried since thymine
guanine to adenine adenine guanine and
thymine cytosine so so far the editing
efficiency is freezing based editing for
these changes is higher than using the
primary ting technique but what really
makes prime editing standout is its
versatility and ability to incorporate
many different types of changes where I
space editing it's much more limited so
we've now talked all about that base and
that's time to move on to some like it
hot so in addition to you optimizing the
editing of the core components of the
system they also tested the editing
conditions and one thing they tested was
the temperature and so as you can see in
this bigger hair they saw a greater
percentage of the site at it at a higher
temperature so it's unlike at I guess if
that's unnecessary
anyway now on to a bit of a level
biology how well this is editing
technique work in actual plants as a PC
just testing the system so the main
challenge is actually getting the prime
editing components into the plants and
see that they use our crew bacterium
mediated transmission which turns out
something I learnt at GCSE not a level
but anyway agro bacterium is a bacterium
and it's infects plant and when it does
this it transfers some of its own DNA
into the infected plant cells DNA and
this can be exploited to get the DNA
including the prime editing system into
the plants so what you do is you have
the DNA construct that expresses the
caste line pretty needed for prime
editing along with the different guide
RNAs and the idea is to put this genetic
construct into a grey bacterium and then
the ugly bacterium can then infect an
input this DNA into the plant cell and
then the plant will then express this
caste 9 prime militant system and
hopefully as you would hope to edit and
achieve the desired genome editing in
the plant so the team did this and
tested deletion substitutions and multi
nucleotide substitutions and they had
some success which is awesome so just
before the video finishes we'll do a
quick round up of the key take-home
messages of this publication so the main
aim of this publication was to achieve
primary thing and adapt it to be able to
use it implants and they did this by
testing a variety of different types of
editing and to do this they had to
optimize a system not only by the guide
RNA design but also the editing
conditions as we discussed with
temperature so plant primary thing was
able to achieve a variety different
types of edits carve it was slightly
less efficient then the current base
editors call transition point mutations
but again you have to remember that
primary thing is a lot more flexible and
so I think there's the work to be done
in optimizing the system for plants but
as stated in the last sentence of this
publication the fertility of plant prime
editing has the potential to advance
beneath plant breeding and functional
genomics research so will be exciting to
see how plant prime editing is used in
the future and so as always thank you
for listening